I got an iPhone 6
mostly because I wanted a bigger screen
for porn sometimes I masturbate to porn
while my husband is sleeping right next
to me I secretly love hentai porn it's
embarrassing just found out my dad is
running a famous porn blog on tumblr I
used to follow him
I bought a waterproof phone case just so
I could watch porn in the shower I made
a porn video with my roommate because
we're broke and can't afford to rent i
buy Visa gift cards in order to purchase
porn memberships that are $1.00
three-day trials that way I'm not
putting my bank account at risk I love
when my roommate goes away for a while
because I can play porn on max volume
whenever I watch porn
instead of getting turned on I just
learned I watched so much porn that I
automatically open an incognito tab out
of habit I've developed a habit of
getting up an hour earlier than I need
to so I can watch porn watching amateur
porn made me feel much better about what
I'm packing down there when people ask
what I do I say I'm an actor it's easier
than saying I work in porn once when I
didn't have a smartphone I drove around
with my laptop to find free Wi-Fi to
watch porn I told my boyfriend I didn't
like him watching porn because it lowers
my self-esteem but really it's because I
don't want him to find the ones I'm in I
installed the porn blocker on my
grandpa's laptop as a joke he just
bought a new computer and said the old
one broke my friend did I casually watch
porn together my parents realized that I
paid for porn instead of getting it free
they didn't care that I watched it but
they gave me a whole speech about free
porn I'd like to be a gay porn star
[Music]